well race was front and center on the
Democrat debate stage last night and
kind of permeated the media spin
afterwards here to break it all down
candice owens founder of the blex it
movement and author of the forthcoming
book blackout and Monique Presley
attorney and Democratic strategist
ladies all right twenty twenty Democrats
there they're often in my mind falsely
accusing President Trump of being a
racist but candidates like Budaj edge
are increasingly applying that label to
all Trump supporters do you think that
people who support president from and
his immigration policies are racist
anyone who supports this is supporting
racism sees more yes Cynthia the media
took it a step further suggesting
Hillary Clinton was right to call Trump
supporters deplorable if they're
supporting what Donald Trump is doing
and if what he's doing is racism well
then what do you say about the folks who
are cheering him up it's a great point
her comment about you know basket of
deplorable so I think she wishes she had
said the time turns out she was dead on
well at least everyone's being now
honest how they feel I'd rather have
everyone get it all out there they want
to cause deplorable so I'll wear that
badge no problem Candice they're going
too far here I think this is actually
Einstein's definition of insanity doing
the same thing over and over again and
expecting different results I don't see
how they could be falling into this trap
again and look here's here's what
they're saying they're saying I'm a
racist I support Trump I'm a black
American they're saying that I want to
see a society come together that I can't
actually live in the problem with that
is it's not only insulting to Americans
but it requires no intellectual depth
try to actually consider what happened
in 2016 and learn from what happened in
2016 but they can't because they're too
arrogant mayor Pete monique seems to
times be pretty kind of um have a
moderate approach the way he debates and
speaks and I think there's an attractive
candidate in many ways to a lot of
people that actually surprised me coming
from him if they're coming from South
Bend it's an interesting communities
very diverse but I never think it's a
winning thing to attack Americans attack
Trump would go at it but attack
Americans I think that's that's that's a
no-no
he wasn't attacking Americans he just
calls amaurosis he
attacking a point of view he said if
you're supporting a racist policy than
you're a racist if you support a policy
that says go out on the street and hit
every fifth person with blonde hair
named Laura you probably or a person
lost how to attack every fifth person
with blonde hair named Laura what he was
saying is if you're supporting
immigration policies that are racist
then you too are racist because you
support racist thing he didn't say the
word but you have to actually listen to
the question before the analysis of
answer you know what person you're a
person that supports not methodology but
I could be asking you what color the sky
is or I could be asking you what color
the but but what's bending him this is
Donald Trump today but I think was today
yesterday I'm losing track of time but
who said we're on the verge of something
really big with immigration I think you
know Jared Kushner has a 600-page plan
that's I think it's on its way to
capital are already there which I think
it's gonna include you know handling
legal immigration illegal immigration to
come together in some compromise if
that's racist then boy we really are in
trouble in the United States I mean
that's a big big deal they're working on
that which they've been working on it
for about eight months and people are
going this is racist well I guess we're
never gonna make any progress on
anything but isn't it kind of if if was
a fifth we'd all be drunk I mean are we
really in the what third year in the if
this is really then it would reload
Obama the big do Bhama do on the border
deported more people than four people is
a racist under that dynamic that makes
it a president I don't think he is so
you're in favor of the more deportation
more green hair Tommy's our resident we
were agreeing we're agreeing that trumps
the president should follow along the
country illegally percent agreeing on
that actually we're not the Democrats
don't agree on that Democrats want to
decriminalize all illegal immigration
Democrats you and I are being on that
lady's President Trump is creating the
space force but Cory Booker wants to
create the race force watch racism
exists the question isn't who in who
isn't a racist it's who is and isn't
doing something
about racism if I am President of the
United States we will create an office
in the White House to deal with the
problem of white supremacy and hate
crimes Canas what of that the moonshot
I'm gonna say this Elizabeth Warren
wants to be President Bernie Sanders
wants to be President Cory Booker does
not wish to be President he is out here
for fame he's out here for moment he's
always been this person he's a
narcissist at his core he just he is not
to be taken seriously and we should stop
letting him have these moments I am
Spartacus in Congress this is all about
Cory Booker he's not a serious candidate
and him even saying racehorses a part of
a part of his his programming he loves
attention he loves that we're discussing
him and no one on the left or right
she'd be taking Cory Booker on a punch
president agree President Trump in the
face a few weeks ago right yeah exactly
as you met him you know what do you want
matter where you have no I'm saying
Vince mental determination of what he
wants I've met him I take him at it just
call for a recess five seconds ago it's
Cory Booker that's where we are right
now logic train of thought Cory Booker
was speaking about a very real issue
which is white supremacy all you have to
do is 15 minutes from now go down my
timeline and you'll understand the very
big difference between someone who is
Candice someone who is you and someone
who write a lot of my time and say but
are they saying get a noose pants around
man checks are a breeze this make sense
you don't have to know somebody to come
to me about what they say you made that
point clear because the first segment
wasn't we know what they want then why
are you commenting on Trump I just asked
a few new and I'm just sure I answered
the question no but I am allowed to
comment on him we don't hide in the back
your comment I just said it's not like I
said he's like oh come on I'm gonna
that's what we do tonight but Ryan I'm a
little like hold on about what people
say and what they do comment about their
intent on hold on coming about what I
want because how do I know
early comment on my trunk when I do the
show I have no idea what that man wants
okay not sure he knows we can't
well he wants me and you know because
you know him guys we gotta go if he
wants to be some prosperity and that's
what he's delivering and by the way we
come in on people all the time can't
that we haven't met that's kind of what
we do actually has two historians they
write about what they it is been all
tamari we gotta go see to comment on
intention are out knowing people comment
on words okay because I'm commenting on
and by the way and by the way I gotta go
we're gonna go we're gonna go - we're
gonna get cut off guys I gotta go ladies
thank you by the way I don't believe
Barack Obama is a racist
I believe he actually deported a lot of
people from this country and under their
judgment he would be considered a racist
today but they play it play a different
set of rules to him